safe spaces trigger warnings social
justice and identity politics careful
now because there could be another
millennial pet peeve coming your way
courtesy of officer snowflake that's
right the home office has been told in a
police survey that rookie officers have
been wrapped in cotton wool our
routinely shocked that police are
expected to work nights and weekends and
do not like confrontation okay hold on
hold on let's cut generation broke some
slack shall we
perhaps Millennials are a bit
emotionally volatile and narcissistic
but there was a generation that came
before them all so obsessed by abstract
idealism over practicalities it's you
baby boomers that gave birth to those
dastardly Millennials before they grew
up you spent all their money
destroyed their planet and made
home-owning nigh on impossible for them
and now we miserable Gen Xers a stop
between two bickering hippie generations
full of hot yeah so take responsibility
for your own work buckos pull yourselves
up from your man bonds and stop bullying
your own children so is your central
point here that people are going into
the police force and they're
ill-equipped for what is required of
them or is it more around actually we've
got what you would perceive or some
people perceive as generation of
snowflakes and it is the parents fault
no I actually don't think there is much
of a difference between generations I
don't think there's any data to support
that behavior behavioral changes are
more directly associated with a change
in circumstances that we find ourselves
in so for example I'd wind and moan if
house prices went up the way they did
and I was in my 20s right now because
that means I can never get on the
housing ladder
so the whinging isn't innate to the
generation it's because the generations
opportunities have been cut back because
of the behavior of their parents
generations and they're the ones
complaining that these law whinging am
owning but they're but for me when I
think about and I do have younger
younger brothers and a fair few young
people that would fit into the category
of what some people would describe as a
snowflake and I sit there and I think
one of the challenges is society and
expectations and aspirations is change
in extraordinarily when I grew up if I
wanted anything
whether it was a pair of shoes or a bag
or anything I had to go and work and I
even had to pay a board when I was a
teenage girl - my parents would be at
home when I think of say some of my
nieces and nephews etc they are given a
lot of stuff I think that a lot of
younger people have a sense of
entitlement but I don't think we're
helping because as a society if I even
think about universities we're
protecting people from speech that there
may not like opposing views if I think
of a playground at school half the kids
can't even go and play on a climbing for
him in case they fall off because the
parents are going to be running to go
and sue health and safety so I just
think that we are we do need to step
back a little bit and make sure that
we're preparing young people for the
world in which they're genuinely gonna
live I would hear others but I doesn't
say in essence what I'm saying is these
are the same old debates being recycled
from one generation about the younger
generation so whereas today whatever
it's you know I used to run around until
sunset without a mobile phone and my
mother never used to know where where I
was and today they're always stuck to
their phones but in those days my
parents would say that to me about
watching whatever on you know playing
Street Fighter 2 on my Sega Megadrive so
it's the same old debates we're
rehashing and actually actually a lot of
the snowflake behavior I mean the hippie
generation began all of that they
started it to save margins I I'm almost
speechless here you didn't miss your
trigger warning before you you know
vicious assault which I am yes I've
personally I don't know if I can if I
can stay here on this program aerated
about about all of this I think that
there is probably something to be said
about if you're a young person you want
to make sure young people expect more of
their employees and they used to I'm
chairing the company where I'm probably
twice the age of almost everybody else
in the company and their expectations
about the way they should be treated are
way way higher than than when I started
but you've affected more than your
grandparents generation and
but but you know I don't think I mean
frankly if people don't like the idea
being in the cops then go and do
something else I mean you know I I think
this this idea that profession shows you
you know your weekends and all the rest
of it is just wrong there are some
places where you can have that kind of
life
yeah cops ain't in it we're being a bit
harsh on the Millennials though aren't
we
anyone i've got given birth to three
millennials baby I saw my yeah a bit I
mean I don't want to talk personally but
I remember suggesting that my son should
pay rent as he'd been living with us
free for a year he was absolutely
outraged made him say don't worry he'd
already paid for many years made me pay
board and bills as soon as I got a job
if I was under her roof so I was I was
brought up a bit like Michelle but I
think you're right it's a generational
thing we all think that the generation
below us is soft and we had it harder
Deloitte though has done a survey of
Millennials attitudes to work the
workplace in some of their major gripes
so what they say that if I had a choice
49 percent of Millennials would quit
their current job in the next two years
yeah we know because they are dead like
the pay yeah most of them lack of
learning and development opportunities
about a third and they don't feel
appreciated OB boomers stole all their
money make an intervention as Generation
X wedged between and I remember I
remember being called you know the
self-absorbed slacker generation as well
so you're right Majid but every
generation gets accused of all these
things and that's gone on for four
decades I would suggest that the
difference with Millennials though is
that they are the first generation for
whom there isn't the expectation that
they will be better off than the
previous shell of course they can come
out they are you know they have to deal
with unaffordable housing a Carius
employment if it's interesting Rachel
that you mention the Learning and
Development
but a third of them are interested in
that which suggests to me that if we're
trying to look at making the most of
Millennials in the workforce and they
are that the majority chunk of the
workforce and they will be more so going
forward but maybe that's the aspect to
focus on that if they're asking for
professional development
maybe the employers I think it's
profound it's it really it's a really
important one this is the first
generation actually probably in in
living memory where the children are
going to have a lower standard living in
their parent however I think what we
should also say when it come to come
back to the cops because that's what
this was about let's just remember that
policing now is not what it used to be I
mean being a copper used to be walking
around with big boots and then you made
somebody by the collar actually today's
police officers are just as likely to be
sitting behind a computer screen going
through reams and reams of data so
actually the Millennials who are playing
games and all the rest of it in their
basements frankly cops could be the
right place for them also think about
the way policing has changed in the
sense that if you've got rising crime
and stabbings and what have you more
police are now being attacked by
suspects than ever before as well and
they're not getting to getting the
mental health support that they actually
need so you've got this generation that
can't afford to get in the housing
ladder whose wages are basically
stagnated who are observing inequality
rise who are watching the fact that
they're not going to be wealthier than
their parents generation and on top of
that crimes going up you know you don't
feel safe I'd be complaining if I was
them I'd be upset and insecure about the
world I mean it doesn't make what they
do correct I mean I don't accept this
notion of you know if I don't like what
you say shut you down but there is I
think there is some so there are some
psychological factors at play I'm happy
with their jobs they want to leave after
generation they've gotta fix this now
because you know the baby boomers were
we're tyring yeah well you've spent all
their money no it's our money